what's up here my name is Hector love to
show what you wanted to tell you a quick
story and get your opinion on it
let's hear more I'm gonna I went to
family reunion recently
and there's this email that I've never
met I wasn't aware she was Keen until
later on
we ended up talking or hit it off and
everything
and then we went out in a couple dates
ended up hitting it
and then come to find out my mom told me
she's one of my second cousins
I'm just kind of
I don't know what to think about myself
kind of
I don't feel bad because I didn't know
her but
I also don't want to enjoy it because
she's yeah let me know what you think
about that man
well brother I think this is actually a
great call that some listeners can give
feedback to you know
um
I think there's like a rule of thumb
when it comes to incest you know and uh
I don't know what it is though what's
the rule of thumb
can you Google that please that what's
the rule of thumb with incest
uh yeah I can Google that
are you talking about like what's legal
because I know some State's second
cousin is legal well I I'm pretty sure
that first
I believe first cousin is legal
no no
second cousin
I mean
I think it depends on what browser
you're using then because they
24 States prohibit marriages between
first cousins
so I'm going to go out on a limb you
know
or is uh
yeah I'm gonna go out on a limb here
okay here we go
cousin marriage legal I'll tell you
where it's legal
Texas
California huh
Colorado
New Mexico Alaska Hawaii
Tennessee Georgia Florida New York wow
that's a really cross I mean that cross
is like political lines and everything
my my thing is this man
here's how you know if you shouldn't
have sex with a sibling not a sibling
but a
someone who's at well first of all
you're at a family reunion bro
maybe not a good place to
even consider sex
you know I don't know if you just you
need to wear a sign or something a
family reunion or what do you I mean
like
if you walk into a family reunion
you shouldn't walk out of there with
some chick's number bro that's crazy bro
you are I mean you're a good guy but you
also seem like you could have some
sexual predator issues
you know and I'm not judging you but I'm
just saying
every everybody else is gonna
and if you man you can't if you like
what am I what are we saying here Zach
I mean that was my point is if you're
going to a family reunion like what are
you was it a mistake yeah
I mean how many people are at the I
didn't have a family it's a Mexican
family reunion dude there could be it's
at a park I'm sure there could be
upwards of two to six thousand people
there I mean there's anybody getting off
a bus in La will probably stop I mean
it's
I'm sure that some of the
I'm sure there's a lot of vague
paperwork at the reunion
is all I'm saying
which is fine Felice Navidad maybe you
know what I'm saying but I'm sure I
understand I think how it could happen
maybe a little bit more
if if there's a lot of people at the
reunion and Mexican people like to hang
out at the park man that [ __ ] is no joke
everybody knows it that's
they're like a part of their culture so
what does he want to know here you think
I think he's just wondering if he should
feel bad about it or not okay
um look I think it's good you're
reaching out to people because you don't
know you know what some of the laws or
bylaws are regarding you know familial
sexual contact
and uh
look I've seen people have sex that
should not be having sex
and I've seen the children of that and
that's where God really throws his two
cents in when that baby rolls out and
you're like damn you know
this thing's got you know a little extra
spine on it or something you know things
got you know
that thing's got an extra you know it's
got an extra thumb near his ass or
whatever you know what I'm saying like
that's when you know
like damn it's but you know this little
buckaroo's got four rows of teeth
you know and two of them's on his butt
hole you know what I'm saying that's
when you're like oh damn
shouldn't have done that
so I think you know there's a general
rule of thumb where I'm from you got to
walk at least 300 feet before you pull
your dick out
and I think that's a good rule to keep
anybody off incest or anything like that
also whenever you're about to pull your
wiener out say get away from me and then
name everybody in your family
and so that way you would make sure you
didn't have sex with somebody you
shouldn't be
so the second you break it out get away
from me Timothy get away from me Mom
Rhonda Papa
uh Christy you know Emmanuel or whatever
whoever is
then that way you're setting yourself up
for the best
but good luck out there man I would yeah
don't yeah you know not to have sex at a
family reunion man you know it
you know what I'm saying I'm kind of
p-footing around it here you know it
you know it man
I mean I don't know what's going on in
the world where you have to call in that
people are doing sex with family
I mean how many years we have to learn
this rule
how many times do we have to learn this
rule as a society that you can't have
sex with a member of your family
because it isn't safe genetically bub
you're going to give birth to a [ __ ]
hot air balloon with legs dog
you're going to give birth to something
that's going to live in a lava lamp bub
and God don't want that and you don't
want that
you don't want to babysit a lava lamp
you don't want somebody Wheeling your
kid across and he's you know you know
and he just got a little lava in him and
he can't even he can barely make the
lava to say the words dad maybe once a
year
you don't want that
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one